hey everyone it's Mike from orphos here
and welcome back to my channel I'm glad
you could join me for today's video
we're going to be talking about uh
cumulative Delta because you know
today's topic sort of came in off of a
back of a couple comments on cumulative
Delta before we jump in if you enjoyed
learning from these videos don't forget
to subscribe and click the notification
Bell so you never miss a new upload and
if you find today's video helpful be
sure to hit the like button for me and
leave a comment sharing your biggest
takeaway you know I love hearing your
feedback and you know oftentimes I do
make a video follow-up to your questions
um just like today so your support
really does go a long way in helping me
create more content just like this so if
you're getting value from my channel be
sure to subscribe and hit the like
button and leave a comment below alright
so you know today's topic it came on the
back of a couple of questions from users
recently
um
and there's two there's two comments I
want to talk about here so first learner
4189 asks can we only follow cumulative
Delta along with technical analysis or
do we need to follow in-depth order flow
analysis all techniques of order flow
analysis well
I often say this you could use whatever
parts of order flow analysis you want in
your trading right if you find that
there's something that helps you use
that piece okay because
I I know for a fact that there are
Traders right who specifically buy my
software just to use it because they're
looking at one aspect in the order flow
that my software highlights Okay so you
know if you already have an existing
method of trading
by all means if you can add order flow
to it to make it more effective go for
it right so
um
you know if cumulative Delta is sort of
like I don't say your your magic pill so
to speak you know your magic beans
when you add it with your technical
analysis for sure use it okay and that
sort of leads into the next question
here
um from uh Gupta says hello sir I'm from
India
Namaste uh want to know if cumulative
Delta is going down continuing but price
is not moving can you explain this
particular case what is going on there
if selling is taken by limit buyer then
why price fall after one hour because
limit buyer will always want to take
price up but in today's market Nifty
fall now you're specifically talking
about Nifty and
yeah
you see this a lot in
a lot of markets honestly not just Nifty
we'll take a look at Nifty in a moment
um but first you know I'll start out
with
uh e-minis okay because you know today
this Market you know we've been in a
Range 08 High to 95 low so about you
know a pretty quiet session today and
you can see there's areas where there's
big rises in
cumulative Delta price is rising okay
you got this little bit of Divergence
here taking place actually
um let's just get the drawing tool out
here what I want I just want F2 just
align keywords of Delta
going down
to two
price made a new high okay so you have
this Divergence yeah and and you know
Delta continued going lower yeah price
did go lower generally you know what
what you have right with cumulative
Delta is
um you know when price is declining
cumulative Delta will should decline if
price is generally moving up
killative Delta should be moving up
right because what you have obviously
you know what is deltas and that
difference between aggressive buyers and
aggressive sellers in the bar so
if you have more aggressive buyers right
people that are removing that liquidity
from the market people that are lifting
the offers right price should go up
just as if you have sellers going down
and clearing out the limit bids right
the bids in the market price should go
down okay generally speaking right but
there are instances like today in the
gold where you kind of have the opposite
happening right you have gold prices
going higher
but what's cumulative Delta doing
cumulative Delta is going lower now I'm
just using the cumulative Delta charge
from that's provided by Ninja Trader
right when you have the paid license so
you know you could look at the actual
cumulative Delta number sometimes you
know I just find it easier for
explanation purposes
um to
have it in in Candlestick format so you
know going back to gupta's question he's
saying in Nifty
um
cumulative Delta was going down but
price was not moving so here in this
case we have something similar
cumulative Delta obviously going down
the price essentially going sideways to
higher okay so what's happening because
he's asking if
um the selling
is being taken by the limit buyers okay
so what you have here right in this case
let me uh
add on a gold chart here really quick
just so you can see the footprint
but what's happening right price is
going up here basically going sideways
cumulative Delta is going lower so you
have more aggressive selling even though
price is going higher and people are
going to say well how can you have
price go higher if there's more
aggressive selling
taking place
okay so let's take a look at the
footprint here
okay
so again you can see in here where it
just made this new high here
right here at an 856 still got
cumulative Deltas positive here now it
turns negative okay it turns negative
here at 8 58.
okay so what does that mean so you can
see in here right even though you got
all these bars negative Delta in here
all these bars negative Delta All These
Bars negative Delta
what are you seeing okay just really
quick you know play the game you know
what do you see well I see this green
bar with negative Delta okay I see Goji
bar here red red green bar with negative
Delta another green bar with negative
Delta
right another green bar with negative
right here right
um I just draw these horizontal lines
here
what is it uh whoops vertical line
rather
come on
vertical line F7
okay one there
one there one there
so we got these bars here with
negative Delta right green candles how
can these green candle how can the
market be going up is well you have
limit bids in here
that are basically absorbing that
aggressive selling right that's what's
giving support to this market right you
see the 116 the 127 the 126. see the 86
114 92
obviously here 83 53 68 68 right even in
this bar I mean there's a green candle
right you got 50
24 31 27 even here 48 right so you know
that there's strong buyers there
absorbing
what strong selling is right and because
if this if you didn't have these strong
sellers there in the market are strong
buyers rather the strong bids in this
market with this selling
you know the market should be going down
right we should be trading at 54.
but just by looking at the cumulative
Delta going down as price is rising I
sort of get in the sense that hey you
know what there's probably some
absorption taking place in the market
right and you can see it there
just by looking at the volumes in the
footprint right I mean this one here
again another positive
green candle but negative Delta
right
small there another strong negative
Delta with a green candle so I know that
there's bids in the market here here
here you know 63 61 63 10 63 40 6350
6360 okay so I know that there's these
bids in the market
right 52.
and again if he's even take a little bit
more granular look
the heaviest bid is coming where it's or
the heaviest volume in the bars coming
on the bid side here in this bar
maybe this volumes coming in where on
the bid side of this bar
this one is equal 34 and 34.
right but these are some of the clues
that you're looking for
in
the footprint right I mean can you so
again you know sort of going back to
cumulative Delta you know can I just use
cumulative Delta
um with technical analysis well of
course you can
I just like to use it a little bit
deeper right and actually look at what's
taking place now maybe what you might
want to do is change your chart to a
Delta chart
okay Delta chart is going to give you
Delta at Price okay so let me just
remove
um
these lines here
right but you can see right this green
candle where's
the Delta it's all negative
but the bar is going up right because
what's taking place so I know I've got
absorption
I know I've got
buyers coming in here to you know work
limits to absorb whatever selling
because remember you're at the high of
the day
you got selling coming in but the
Market's not going down how do I know
they're selling coming in well it came
with the belt I just watched flip from
positive back here
the negative over here so I know that
there's got to be some bids in this
market absorbing whatever selling is
taking place in here
okay
I mean you could even see it here minus
123 now this is a red candle but still
that's a strong Delta for a price up
here near the high of the day
okay so I mean that's information that
you could use so don't think that oh you
know maybe I'm just going to take one
piece if you can just use cumulative
Delta in your trading okay you know go
for it
now
let's take a look here at the
let me get my go charting platform going
on
because you asked
specifically uh about
the Nifty
okay I'm not sure when this comment came
in came in a day ago so let me just pull
in go charting here because I've noticed
there's a few questions about goal
charting uh the platform
um so let me pull up my
charts and
Nifty futures
all right Nifty futures
um okay let me get cumulative Delta on
here
okay
where are you here here
so you had asked specifically uh
again with the Delta's going down but
price is not moving okay well when price
is moving I mean whether it's going down
or not
or you mean you know the fluctuation
that's taking place is another
um story
so
cumulative Delta is going down down down
down what do I go I put on a five minute
chart here it might be a little bit
easier
someone sort of came in yesterday
okay so cumulative Delta is going down
maybe here right sort of see it dropping
here
the price is not moving
well again
similar thing I mean
you know what's taking place in the
trading
right you have that aggressive sellers
coming in
right but you do have passive limit buy
orders sitting there to absorb
whatever
aggressive selling is taking place you
know you can sort of see it in here
because you know we're sort of you know
dropping in here over this time period
minus 183
K minus 201 minus 200 K minus 199 minus
205 and it looks like price is just
holding steady well when you're looking
at the volumes that's what's going to
give you that extra layer
of what's taking place because you know
there's aggressive selling
taking place but it's there's bids in
there there's limit bids that are
absorbing that selling
okay
so sometimes it's easier if you're using
the Candlestick formats like I just
showed you there with the um
here
right here because you can see like how
this Market is dropping down
and again there's a lot of different
ways you can use it you know I know some
guys they just use cumulative Delta they
just look for Divergence like this
that's all that's their play okay
so anyway uh that wraps up this video on
cumulative Delta I hope you found it
useful to your understanding I hope it
doesn't confuse you a little bit more
let me know would you like me to discuss
next by leaving a comment down below so
if you enjoyed this video make sure you
hit that like button and subscribe to my
channel so you don't miss any of my
upcoming content thanks again for being
part of my community and I'll catch you
guys later bye bye
foreign